The successful managers of the 21st century will be the culturally sensitive ones.
If you are in a business meeting, in negotiations,...
...part of a joint venture or just face to face with someone from a different culture,...
...you gain a competitive advantage from having strategies...
...to deal with the cultural differences you will encounter.
Germans believe that the truth even when unpalatable,...
...will achieve a successful outcome.
The same is true for the Finns.
The English and the Japanese will try not to rock the boat...
...even though the truth is inconvenient.
To the Chinese, there is no absolute truth.
And to the Italians it is negotiable.
The Americans will call the Japanese unethical if they break the contract.
The Japanese say it is...
...unethical for the Americans to apply the terms of the contract...
...if things have changed.
In countries such as the U.S.,...
...Peru and Kuwait, conversation is a two - way process,...
...where one partner takes up after the other one leaves off.
In Finland and Japan,...
...silence is an integral part of social interaction,...
...and lulls in conversation are regarded as restful,...
...friendly, and appropriate.
So where does Korea and Koreans fit in the above ideas?
In any case,...
...the more we know about the basic traits of other cultures...
...the fewer unpleasant cultural shocks we are likely to experience.